the medicines and healthcare products  regulatory agency  has this week recommended to the uk  government  on the basis of the advice of the  commission on human medicines  that it should agree to the approval for  use  of the covid19 vaccine developed by  pfizer biontech  together with the conditions for its  supply  and use the mhra's recommendation has  been reached  following an extremely thorough and  scientifically rigorous review  of all the evidence of safety  of effectiveness and of quality of the  pfizer  biontech vaccine the uk  government has now accepted this advice  and has made the decision to approve the  vaccine for use  with some conditions in adults aged 16  and over the safety of the public  will always come first and i emphasize  again that  this recommendation has only been given  by the mhra following the most  rigorous scientific assessment of every  piece of data so that it meets the  required  strict standards of safety of  effectiveness  and of quality